- Did you have pets growing up?
I grew up with cats, but now I'm allergic.
- You grew up with dogs. Oh no.
- Yeah. I love them though,
but I'm just allergic.
My daughter hates it. She wants cat.
- I thought I was allergic to my cats,
which was about a year after having them.
I only have them a year.
So very recently,
- Yeah.
- A couple of months ago, maybe 10 months
after having them. I thought
Murphy came up onto me one day
and I'd been away for a
while and I started sneezing.
I thought, oh geez. And
it looked it up online and
of course it said, yes, it can
come on without any warning.
- Yeah.
- Delayed. And I thought, oh no.
But then it only lasted a few days.
I took some antihistamine
and thank God it was grand.
'Cause there is no way
I was giving him back.
- I know.
- I had already resigned
myself to being a sneezing mess
for 16 years. I was like,
(expletive) I'll sneeze.
- I know.
- I just, I'm not giving these.
- Same thing. I rescued a
cat and she, I loved her
and I was like I'm a singer.
And I kept coming home and I was like, and
- No, no, no, no.
- I was like, what is happening?
And then I found, I found a home for it.
- Oh, you did, yeah?
- But I had to give her, I
didn't give her back to the
- No, you're a singer
though, yeah absolutely.
- But, yeah, I was like, I
can't do that Colin. (chuckles)
- No, no, but we had dog
grade, a dog called Shep.
Growing up. Shep was a Collie.
Looked like Lassie.
- Oh
- Yeah. Border Collie, like
Lassie exact same coloring as
- I love animals.
I'm into animals.
- Do you, speaking of
when you were younger
do you ever get to go back to
Ireland? Do you get back much?
- They're honest. That's
the thing isn't it?
They're honest.
Which is sometimes where they
can make you uncomfortable.
Like, if an animal doesn't like
it (gasps) sees the real me.
(Audience laughter)
- Oh this is how I sift out people.
I'm like it senses evil.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
- (laughs)
Animals and babies. They
have (expletive) Texas.
- (laughs)
- Yeah. They know what kind of
day you're having before you
- They're gonna call
you out before you do.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. I know. I'm not a
friend that didn't like animals.
like, I don't trust a person
that doesn't like animals.
- Yeah.
- That's just really messed up.
- No, no I get it.
- Yeah. Well, do you
ever get back to Ireland?
- I do about once a year.
- Yeah.
- Ideally yeah. It's been hard
with actually I went back in
I hadn't been back in a year and a half
and then when things started to quiet down
from whatever surge was
the surge before the film
I had the chance to go back to work
on the west coast of Ireland
with a few friends of mine.
- Oh, that's cool.
- Yeah. And do a thing on the west coast
on an island called Inishmore,
which is the biggest
of three of the islands
that constitute the Ireland islands.
- Yeah.
- Off the coast of Galway.
So it was gorgeous.
I got to work with me
friend Brandon Least again
who I love very much.
- That's cool.
- And Martin McDonough,
the writer director
who I did this film
in Bruges and another thing
Seven Psychopaths with.
So it was kind of a coming back together.
And I know, I knew a lot
of the crew on the film of
the various departments.
- Yeah.
- So it was really like
a family experience.
And I needed it actually, I
didn't know how much I needed.
Cause look, my children are here.
I have two sons, James and Henry
and a bunch of family here.
So I don't spend my days
being melancholy for Ireland.
But when I go back home
and when I land back home
that place makes a sense to me.
- Yeah.
- I feel it in a way
that I don't think I'll
ever feel anywhere else.
And that's fine.
- I love that.
- To the way it's supposed to be.
So it was wonderful to get home.
- Yeah. And not everybody has that.
Some people just like to
go and then they're gone
and I love that you
have that kind of house.
- I have very deep connection to it.
- Yeah.
- Very deep.
- That's cool.
- It gets into you, being
Irish and our history
and our culture and our pains
and the fact that we are an island.
There's no palm trees and coconuts
but we're an island culture.
- Yeah.
- I just found out 25% of
me is from Cork, Ireland.
- Nice.
- Yeah my family from
like, yeah (applause)
the, that part of France and then Cork.
And I was like, you, I wanna go there.
I looked it up now I wanna go.
- That was only 25% of
a clap. That was so much
- I don't, I don't
- That was a quarter of clap
they were doing earlier.
- I feel like they were kind of excited.
- Like yeah, 25. Come back and see us
- Are we supportive? Do we
wanna claim her? (chuckles)
- When you're over 2O percent. Yeah. Yeah.
When you going?
- When you're a mutt
and you're from, America
it's like you wouldn't even know it.
- I would be, if I was American.
- Yeah, you,
- And I'm not gonna say more.
Cause I'm Irish, I'll be hung.
- But you get, excited til
whenever you find out. Yeah.
- I would totally be going back.
- Yeah.
- Where else? Where's the other 75?
- Well, it's like France,
Ireland and England.
- France, Ireland, England.
- And Greece, sorry.
- Oh Greece. Em.
Ah man. So you haven't
been to Ireland ever?
- Oh no, no. I love Ireland.
- Oh you haven't.
- I've never been to Cork.
- You've never been to Cork.
- And apparently they're all from Cork.
- Have you (indistinct) in Ireland?
- Yeah, yeah, oh yeah, yeah.
- Is it? You enjoy it?
- I love Ireland. I've
just gone for vacation.
- They gave you no option. You
enjoy it, I didn't ask you.
- They give you, they have these castle
- No they have these castles,
- Need it.
- Sounds very posh, it
is. But it's affordable.
You can like, you know what I'm saying?
- It is affordable. Where did you stay?
- You can pitch in all your
friends when you rent a castle.
What is it called?
Oh no, that was the one in Scotland.
Sorry, Scotland and Ireland.
- Did you stay in Dromoland
Castle? Did you stay in?
- God, I'm gonna forget it now.
I said it when
- Ashford Castle? Bet you stayed there.
- I'm gonna get back to you.
But I have pictures and everything.
It was beautiful.
- Beautiful.
- I love it and I took the
whole band. Do y'all remember?
I know we're all blanking.
We all literally on tour on where we went.
- Were you though?
- Yeah, 30 minutes
outside of Dublin. Anyway.
- Where did Kelly first stay?
- Yeah. It was cool.
It was so fun. I'm so mad too,
because she was so lovely.
The one, the rain.
But anyway, I love Ireland.
So I thought it was
really cool to find out.